i seriously do not feel like making this
video as i have potentially much to lose
however the overwhelming feeling of
regret that i'd have by not saying this
would be far worse
and by the way i'm filming this on june
11th 2022
so mark my words the complete collapse
of the u.s dollar and the global economy
as a whole is now imminent and this is
going to affect absolutely everyone
whether you're currently poor or rich
this will affect you however it will
affect some people far sooner and more
dramatically than others and the good
news is that by hearing this and
understanding what's coming will give
you time to prepare now two weeks ago on
may 27th i made a video on this topic
however this video is going to lay out
several pieces of lime item evidence
that will show you exactly why this is
happening what reason and what you can
do to prepare and later in this video i
will give you my best advice
now some people will say oh you're
you're fear-mongering you're you're
you're causing panic no i'll have
something to say about that later in the
video too but let me just dive into this
like i said two weeks ago the cost of
literally everything is not only going
up but it's about to skyrocket and we
regret to say that in just the last two
weeks the evidence of this has become
more and more apparent
food fuel and subsequently everything
under the sun
will cost more and will continue to rise
in the in the weeks months and probably
the next two years to come
inflation is at the highest it's been in
40 years
and that is just the beginning inflation
from here on out is going to
dramatically increase as the value of
the dollar continues to diminish
one of the reasons for this is the cost
of fuel
everything that we purchase in our lives
is coming from something that operates
on fossil fuels whether it be a truck
train or airplane as the cost of fuel
goes up so does everything else
one of the reasons why the cost of fuel
is going up is because of the canceled
pipelines here in the united states i
made a point in my prior video
mentioning the keystone pipeline is just
one example and some people
unfortunately focus on that to say well
hey the keystone pipeline is not yet
finished and that has not affected
anything
but the point that i was making or
should have specified better is that
many pipelines that were active have now
been canceled and leases for them
nullified
this has never been done and we went
from pumping oil from under our very
feet to now trying to purchase it from
countries on the complete opposite side
of the world which is thus further
increasing the cost of fuel
unfortunately this is totally by design
and this the fallout of this would have
been known by the experts in this
industry in the field and those who had
the positions of power to do so now
another key factor that's causing the
inflation the cost of everything to go
up is the fact that we've been printing
trillions and trillions of dollars in
just the last few years now printing
money in itself does not just inherently
cause inflation however when you print
money in the form of stimulus checks and
send it out to the masses and the
economy to be spent that does cause
inflation and if you look here between
2010 to 2015 we printed approximately
one trillion dollars which by the way is
a ton of money
however in the last year we've printed
three trillion dollars i'll say that
again one trillion over five years
compared to three trillion in one year
this in itself is catastrophic for the
value of the dollar and collapsing it
now
that being said because of the cost of
everything going up whether it's because
the cost of fuel and the fallout from
that and whether it's the printing of
money and the fallout from that
now that things are costing more money
than ever people are now spending less
and when they do spend they're using
their credit cards hence why the
consumer credit usage and debt is at the
highest ever and will continue to go up
because again if people can't afford to
use their debit cards to purchase things
they're going to use their credit cards
and the numbers are already showing this
this will continue to rise
now because people are spending less
because again cost of everything has
gone up we're now seeing that retailers
whether it be walmart target amazon
their inventories are now too high and
so they are now trying to offload their
inventory because you may not be aware
that when a company has something on
their shelves
they have to pay taxes on it which is
why if you ever wonder when you go to
the store or something like why do they
run out of this why don't they just buy
more well it's because they want to have
a precise amount on hand in order to
avoid paying the taxes on it
so now that people are spending less
these retailers are trying to offload
the product their inventory and the
media is spinning this like oh that's a
good thing you can now get things at a
discount
however
that is perhaps the most short-sighted
way imaginable to interpret this because
as these big box retailers dump their
their products
it will then have a supply and demand
fallout which is that over time as
you're trying to buy these same products
that they have less of the cost of that
will continue to go up as well
and now that people are purchasing less
because everything costs more you're
seeing the evidence of that with the
reduced shipping container rates and now
that they're plummeting in early 2020
during the crisis all of that went up
but now that you're seeing here recently
it is now collapsing that right there is
indicative of the very fact that people
are now spending less and they are of
course spending less because things are
more expensive this is like a domino
effect it carries over everywhere
now one of the more alarming things that
i've came across in the last couple days
is the fact that big tech industry uh
corporations are now rescinding their
job offers
this right here is a massive red flag so
here's what happened you have people
that have accepted a job offer put in
their notice and right before they're
about to start their new position that
they're all excited about the job offer
was rescinded and this is happening to
thousands and thousands of people and
this is going to carry over into other
industries as well and far sooner than
you think
this is not just indicative of a
so-called recession
this and everything else i've already
mentioned is indicative of what will
become an absolute depression
because again the cost of food will
continue to go up the cost of everything
under the sun is going to go up
so here's what you can do to prepare and
i understand that some people are tight
on money and they will not be able to do
this and perhaps you may have to use
your credit card and i'm not giving
financial advice here
but
you know now is the time to do something
so
as the prices where they are now like
you might be thinking well the prices
are high as it is i can't stock up i
have news for you the prices are gonna
are gonna skyrocket from here on out in
fact the price of fuel will be over ten
dollars a gallon far sooner than you
think in fact i believe that in the very
near term before the end of twenty 22 i
wouldn't be surprised if people are
begging or wishing that they were paying
five dollars a gallon guys i don't want
to be the doomsday guy and i understand
this sounds like fear-mongering but this
is guys this is math like this is coming
and by knowing this information will
give you a chance to prepare and that's
what's most important
so i recommend if you can
buy everything that you normally
purchase and buy in bulk while the
prices are low if you can stock up on
food whether it be canned food rice and
beans and other things i would recommend
doing so so that way if the cost of food
or when the cost of food skyrockets as
people start clearing out the shelves
you at least have food on hand to
withstand you
i also recommend buying everything else
whether it be toothpaste or
undergarments and pretty much anything
else that you normally take for granted
i'm telling you it's not just going to
be the lack of access because of
diminished supply chain but when you can
get a hold of something it's going to be
egregiously expensive
me personally i'm buying two years worth
of food going to costco buying bags of
rice and beans and canned food
and seasoning and salt and other things
because
if things really hit the fan which i
fear that they will
and let me just say for people in the
united states i'm not suggesting you're
going to starve to death
but throughout the world we're going to
see this there's already food riots in
sri lanka and other places and this is
going to continue guys
so now is the time to prepare now some
people are going to say well by you
sharing this you're causing a purchasing
panic you're making it worse
that's not true this is going to happen
even if absolutely nobody said anything
about this whatsoever it's still going
to happen now let me also say because
people like well you have a large
following you know you're going to make
this worse well first of all
literally half my audience is
international
and half my audience entirely is
probably going to even watch this video
and it's not like even half the audience
that's in the united states is all
living the same town and gonna clean out
the same grocery store
you understand so it's like
if you're somebody because i saw my
prior video people were giving me
criticism saying well you're causing
fear you're making it worse it's like
okay well if you really feel that way
well then don't prepare it all do your
part and don't buy anything and don't
tell your friends and loved ones to
prepare as well
that's not real advice do not do that
i'm not suggesting that but do you see
my point i made another argument in my
in my prior video or example or analogy
i should say which is that like this is
a mathematical certainty that this is
happening and it's all by design
the cost of fuel and everything else
this does not have to happen
i don't want to get into the conspiracy
side of things all i recommend is that
you look into these things yourself and
start asking questions but if nothing
else you just need to understand that by
having the heads up for this if this is
imminent and it is imminent i use the
example of the titanic that the water
went over five bulkheads it could have
stayed afloat with four but not five
guys that's where we're at we're over
five bulkheads the us dollar is going to
collapse inflation is going to go
through the roof like it's happened in
many other countries throughout history
like we all believed and i'm talking
about the western world as well it's not
just people in the united states guys
this is going to go over everywhere
europe south america everywhere
um and so i do have good news and i i
hate being the doomsday guy but i'm like
guys this is happening whether we want
it to or not and you're better off
knowing so you can have a heads up and
and i do believe that the future is
bright i believe that the best times are
ahead of us how however i do see that
things can get worse before they get
better and be be take positivity in
knowing that other people hundreds of
millions of people probably billions of
people throughout history have suffered
far worse than us our quality of living
and other things and conveniences will
be diminished um in certain creature
comfort things that we have will be
reduced but we will make it out of this
and this is the time to bond together
and unite as a community i highly
recommend that you become closer with
family that might not be the case for
everyone that might not always be an
option but friends family and loved ones
now is the time to work together because
in the weeks months and i suspect the
next two years is kind of what i'm
suspecting and when things are going to
get quite dire you'll be far better off
working together there's a saying a
quote you have to if you don't find a
way to live together you will die alone
and and that's kind of where we're at is
that if by working together as community
you'll find a way to improvise and adapt
and overcome
um again so hey let me just say i don't
want to be the doomsday guy i know
there's people watching this that come
to my channel for ancient stuff and
everything else and let me just say my
next video is on atlantis and i'll
continue to make videos on these awesome
topics
and i want to try to avoid this stuff
but guys i'm one of these guys that like
you know
when i have something to say and i know
something's coming i just feel the
overwhelming urge to scream it from the
rooftop so i'm doing my part and i'm
doing what i believe to be right i'm
doing the hard right instead of the easy
wrong i stand to make money making my
other videos on fun topics whereas this
i stand to make no money and potentially
even worse and put myself in jeopardy
when it comes to my own finances but i'm
like i just can't live with myself by
knowing what's coming and not saying
something and i encourage you to share
this with others
not everyone's going to believe it not
everyone's going to listen um but but at
least you would have spoken your piece
and given people a chance
to know what's coming and maybe down the
road they will understand how you were
right and that
you try to warn them and you know maybe
they'll have a chance to react before
it's far too late but that said i'm
going to close this up and go work on my
atlantis video i ask or i would you know
if you want to if you want to support me
and if you want to get other knowledge
and things to come support me on locals
patreon and subscribe star where i'll be
partnering and doing podcasts i've been
i've been partnering with people behind
the scenes people from my past
professionally and otherwise that are in
the know that have been sounding the
alarm on this discreetly among people
they know
and i'm going to be interviewing some of
them and sharing what they've what
they've been sharing with me in fact
some of these same things i've been
shared upon with a very dear friend
who's definitely an expert in this in
this field and so i'm sharing these
things guys because it's like it's true
so anyways that being said i'll close it
up here my name is jimmy corsetti my
channel is called bright insight leave a
comment and share your thoughts on all
of this um and hit the like button
subscribe and share with others a little
you know have the heads up as well but
that being said be optimistic
you know embrace a positive mindset and
i'm telling you we can all do this
together and we'll make it out of this
much love everyone